yeah totally works wait that work
totally worked
Oh what's up guys this is the making of
for our Assassin's Creed 3 video we're
in Los Angeles right now but we shot
that video in our hometown of Stillwater
Minnesota really cool place it's
beautiful this time of year
perfect so with this video we had the
challenge of trying to match the game in
terms of its fighting style things the
character can do and the look of it
needless to say when we were making this
piece we found out that it was really
hard to replicate the physics of a
videogame in real life but we did our
best and it's a really good challenge
because we've been really looking
forward to doing a project of this for a
while now obviously it's no longer the
Revolutionary War so we had to get in
touch with some War reenactors to get
the authentic British Redcoat experience
also got a bunch of sweet Conner weapons
from my eBay and we need to and we need
to get stuff versions of those same
weapons made so here for example is a
tomahawk that's made out of wood
scraping and silver and decorated so
just look like the authentic prop this
one my sister made in her woodshop this
one we got off the eBay yeah check this
out she also made a rope dart with
lasers yeah this is all laser-cut yeah
these are all all the stuff is like
laser-cut so when you're doing a fight
scene with this kind of stuff you have
to be careful because you listen this
one looks great but it's made out of
metal if you're swinging this around so
you can reel off easily hurt somebody
I'm nervous this make Sam you're gonna
hurt me so that's why it's really
important to have stun weapons made but
because they're moving so fast and
they're all motion blur when they're
using this versus this you can't tell
the difference
exactly so yes except for the slow-mo
shot where it spins and you see those
swings and details yeah and this
slow-motion shot where throws it he's
throwing this one because we show it up
close so once again this is another
stunt dagger that we hadn't made shot
with the laser shot with a laser
preparing his knife has a hook on the
end and a knife on this end had to do a
lot of research to make sure we were
authentic this is actually shoots that
into his hand he goes Johnny chops
people love with it just like that one
of the most important parts of making
this video was getting the choreography
right because unlike the other sets in
screwed games Assassin's Creed 3
features a lot more gunplay and so we
had to like work in new
with like muskets you know there's just
a lot of new moves and combinations and
stuff in the game that we tried to
actually recreate with their actors that
can we saw the announcement trailer at
around the time to e3 so it's really
sweet cinematic where Connor comes
running across the field and just like
goes crazy like beating up British
troops he's just like charges into a
line of troops and I don't know how he
does it but he just does it there's a
lot of like really cool ideas that
revolutionary weapons and kind of like a
kungfu style brought to the table like
for example he takes musket stabs a guy
with it and then pulls the trigger to
cause it to kick back and hit another
guy in the face so we tried to do the
same thing in our video where we utilize
muskets not only because they were guns
because their blades gun blades done
bleep like in Final Fantasy 8 but not as
yeah if you think about it the
Revolutionary War was kind of steampunk
guy names in from EMC you guys have
probably heard of those guys that do a
bunch of stunts and a bunch of different
things like sync and like in the
sleeping dogs and other stuff anyways
this guy names in came up with the
choreography and working with Shane who
played Connor we worked with Shane
previously on sing in episode 5 he's got
a really small role he's a guy who cut
the keys and Charlie went to work when
this project came around we were like
wait a second we know someone who looks
strikingly close to the character in
game and he can also do sweet moves so
let's let's do this
so it turns out that freerunning in the
trees is not as easy as the video game
makes it look also real-life trees don't
grow right next to each other yeah
that's why it's not like a jungle gym
it's like there's a tree over here and a
tree way over there and if you want to
get between the two it's like good luck
man when we want to do a little bit tree
parkour to bring that part of the game
to life we had to do a lot of searching
and eventually he found a branch for
Shane could run up like swing around it
and hop into the tree from there also it
was raining then you can't see it on
camera but everything was very wet and
slippery so change it a very good job of
not breaking any bones that day for the
part where he backflips off the branch
that's actually another branch Lee found
that was like this far off the ground
and I'm just like down here with the
camera and then changes doesn't back
foot off a bit but in the sequence it
looks like he's jumping way off the top
branch that's pretty cool yeah so talk
about that why are you guys about sake
easily
hands down one of the coolest moves we
have in the video is
rope dart stunts we're basically the
assassin running through the trees gets
on bond to a branch goes what's up with
the freakin rope dart and stick us like
that sticks the captain in the back see
it's like this and then he jumps up and
hangs them it's all like metaphorical
because it's like a metaphor for like
justice and being hanged
so actually doing a stunt like this
isn't really physically possible if you
have two people that weigh about the
same amount you can't really do that in
order to do this stunt we rigged up the
tree branches with a bunch of pulleys by
essentially having people climb up there
attach them to random places and that
goes from the assassin to the tree
branch back down to the captain back up
to the tree branch and then over to the
side where we have extra people pulling
on the line for the stunt and really
cool their motion actually influences
each other so it's pretty accurate to
how they actually do it in the game now
there's one bit of danger in this and
that is we've taken people out of their
harnesses or putting them into the
harnesses you got another person hang in
there so if one person is up in the tree
and you clip somebody who knows and hit
the ground yeah that's why we had the
rope on the side too so you pull it all
tight and hold it tight but we could
clip people in or unclip people no one
actually no one actually got hurt it's
really fun so is our first time ever
using authentic Revolutionary era
muskets and fit lock pistols and all
that kind of snow it's really sweet
they're really cool like the way they
actually work and how like you have a
little powder pan a piece of Flint that
hits it and lights and that goes in the
barrel yeah basically little explosion
shooters is a really nice thing is you
just don't put a bullet in there and you
have a blank firing gun so use that when
the captain shoots that Conor and you
dodge the book this is really fast
literally this far away and just like
shooting like right over he's like still
the same to close to those don't ever do
that that's really dangerous now for the
muskets when you shoot the musket the
powder in the pan actually shoots up and
it's designed that way so that when
you're aiming down the musket it doesn't
explode into your face it's we had to
alter the choreography a little bit so
it's up here and also have him use his
foot to protect his eyes so he pulled
the trigger there the flash in the pan
is all directed in the state direction
and oh yeah by the way all those shots
where people are getting like arrow
through the net
and then bayonetted in the sheds through
then she basically those are all like cg
weights those cg arrows and cg bayonets
we would basically film the stunts with
just a musket with no bayonet on it and
we'd have our sass and run up and stab
just like the blunt gun into a someone's
chest with like a little padding on and
then later in post we would basically
take a 3d model of a bayonet and track
that roughly on to the end of the gun so
just tracked by hand by yeah track right
hand we're not using like automatic crap
and same for the arrow when you're
dealing with really fast-moving blurry
footage and stuff like that there's no
way like an automated tracking system
can handle that so you basically just
have to go there and like line it up by
eye as best you can but because it's
fast moving and all blurry and
everything and get away with a lot by
tracking it by yeah it's obviously the
easiest and fastest way to go sometimes
here's something that Nika wants to talk
about it's the costume now I wasn't
quite bad already
yeah the housen was not so this is
another thing that you learn is like boy
that guy's a cool costume I bet it's
really practical and useful yeah it's
really good if you're like slowly
walking around a convention center like
being really careful not having one
anyone touch you when he's doing flips
and tricks and all that kind of stuff
like the hoods flying off the tails
flying over his head and all that kind
of stuff so apparently there's a lot of
safety pins Haden inside the costume in
the video game because that's how we got
to stay down we got the hood to stay
down by putting a beanie on him yeah
then safety pinning the hood to the
beanie and when he's doing all the
tricks like flipping around the tree we
just had the safety pin all the
coat-tails and everything down we also
started to learn how impractical having
a hood is when you're trying to
assassinate people physically huh-huh
like trying to look up underneath it man
that guy's so dark and brooding I can't
see his eyes but I guess he can see me
we actually held auditions for this
piece one of them happened to be really
good that's Cody he played the captain
who's really awesome not to mention all
the soldiers those guys as mentioned are
all from like an actual like
Revolutionary reenactment troop like
we're sitting there trying to catch the
characters and are like okay do we do we
want any like supporting cast members do
we want to do anything for that and
after talking to the guys I realized
wait a second they're re-enactors they
act like they're British
freaking day they gotta be good and so
once we started pointing the camera at
them they're just they got into it
they're having a blast and it was
awesome and it turned out really well
they did a really good job with the
sun's too I wasn't expecting them to be
able to take sweet falls but they
actually did yeah I mean part of the
requirements to be a true reenactor are
being able to shoot your guns at close
range
being able to fake bayonet stabs and
also like falling over and dying a lot
there's a lot of that happening
especially by the British troops
protip if you want your shoot to go
really smoothly you shoot what we I
guess call a video board basically what
it means you could have a cheap camera
and you grab your friends and you go to
location and you start experimenting
with shots you basically record it you
can edit that together to make sure all
your angles are going to work really
well before you go and do the real thing
with a bunch of people and money and
costumes and time all riding on the line
that's a good way to make a shoot go
fast and smooth and make sure you're
gonna get it all done the best thing
about shooting in Minnesota is that no
one's jaded about filmmaking ever he's
excited about it and locations are
plentiful and beautiful and easy to come
by some of the bridge that bridge is
actually the oldest stone bridge in
Minnesota in Los Angeles there's a lot
of great people to work with and there's
a lot of great resources but locations
are almost impossible to come by unless
you're willing to drop a couple thousand
dollars yeah that's rough so I hope you
guys liked the video and learned a
little bit something from this one more
than anything else it's really fun to do
bigger projects like this because it's
very difficult to do on a such a short
schedule like we normally have but if
you want to follow us on Twitter and
Facebook you know do it
Corder out
you